الزلزال اللي صار والدمار الكبير اللي
خلفه فتح كلام ونقاش كثير عن العمران في
المنطقه وطريقته وفي ناس حتى اشعلت
انتقادات لما اعتبرت انه استهتاروا اسلوب
بناء غير امن وناس كثيره امام هذا النقاش
صارت تقول شوفوا اليابان احسن مثال ليه
لانه اليابان من الدول اللي بتقع على خط
الحزام الناري وهذه منطقه زلازل وبراكين
ولمن تعرضت لزلازل كثيره ومنها مدمره
تعلمت من التجربه واتبعت اسلوب عمراني
بخفف الاضرار والناس الان شغاله بتقول انه
يا جماعه تعالوا نتعلم من تجربه اليابان
ايش هي بالضبط تجربه اليابان وكيف وبتخفف
من الاضرار خلونا نعرف من مختص اللي بينضم
الينا من عمان المهندس المعماري والباحث
في اداره المخاطر يزن محادين اهلا فيك
معانا اول شيء خلينا يعني احاول اعرف منك
بس متى بدا اليابانيين في اعتماد هذا
النمط الجديد او الاسلوب الجديد في البناء
اهلا فيك اول شيء خلينا نرجع بالتاريخ شوي
لورا بال193 في واحد تسعه ضرب زلزال كبير
اليابان
140 الف شخص بهذا الوقت وبعد بالحرب
العالميه الثانيه بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بال 1946
بلشت تعمل في قانون جديد ومعايير تصميميه
للمنشات وهذا القانون تطور بعد فتره
بال198 وال 1981 وبعدين 2011 كل ما يصير
زلزال بصير في هناك تطور على هذه المعايير
وعلى القوانين البناء اللي في ايش
الاختلافات الان يعني لما نيجي ننظر على
مباني اليابان في بنائها ايش المختلف عن
المباني في الدول الاخرى
في عنا ثلاث معايير وفي نقطه مهمه كمان
اولا الابحاث العلميه اللي صارت في
الخرسانه المرنه وهي اللي بتتمدد اكثر من
الخرسانه العاديه وتحتف تحتوي على الياف
كيميائيه بيستخدموها كمان في ثلاث معايير
مهمه وهي طبعا العوارض والاعمده
والجدران كلها الها سماكه
بتقاوم الاهتزاز الارضي في كمان معيار
ثاني وهي بيعملوا نوع من المخمدات اللي
بتمتص طاقه الزلازل بحطوها في الاساسات
بتكون عباره عن خرائط مطاطيه سميكه وفي
معيار اخير كمان هي عباره عن طبقات من
الرصاص والفولاذ والمطاط تتحرك بشكل مستقل
فمنفصل الهيكل تبع المبنى عن الارض
فالمبنى نفسه بيهتز بشكل طفيف
كمان عباره عن اسطوانات هيدروليه بتتمدد
يعني بتتمدد وبتنكمش مع التمايل البنايه
طيب يعني يعني هي بيبنوها بطريقه بحيث لما
يصير الزلزال تميل ولكن ما تسقط ولا تتهد
طيب هذا الشيء لما بداوا اعتماد هذا
الاسلوب هل فعلا تم او قله الاضرار من
الزلازل
نعم في
من خلال بحث العلمي في كمان شغله مهمه
عملتها اليابان اليابان عملت صرفت مليار
دولار على نظام انذار زلزالي مبكر بحيث
انه بتبعت للناس قبل 80 ثانيه من وصول
الزلزال وصار هذا الحكي بال 2018
وبال11 واذا بنيجي على التاريخ بنشوف كيف
المباني يعني بال 2011 المباني اتضررت
بشكل كبير بسبب تسونامي بس في مباني ظلت
راكزه وفي نفس الاشي بالالفين 2018 في احد
المدن ضرب زلزال فقدوا خمسه اشخاص و500
القطارات
وطرق البناء كانت والثواني التحذيريه اللي
قبل الزلزال كانت كفيله يعني بتغيير
الكثير وتقليل الاعداد وحتى طريقه البناء
اللي بتقول عليها طيب الان اذا هي تجربه
اثبتت نجاحها على الاقل في الحجم الخسائر
واهم شيء طبعا الخسائر البشريه نحن هنا
بنتكلم عنها الناس جالسه بتتكلم انه لازم
الحكومات تتبع هذا الاسلوب في البناء او
انه ليش لازم تستفيدوا من تجربه اليابان
او هكذا وهكذا وهكذا وفي لون مثلا في
سوريا وتركيا وما الى ذلك الى اي درجه هذا
اللوم واقعي
والله اول اشي حسب يعني دوله زي اليابان
هي بتصرف مليارات الدولارات على البحث
العلمي على التكنولوجيا والحلول المبتكره
زي ما حكيت صرفك مليار دولار على النظام
زلزالي ومبكر بالاضافه انه حمايه الارواح
والممتلكات والامكانات الاقتصاديه شغله لا
تسمى فاحنا علينا بالقراءه دراسه التاريخ
دراسه كل منطقه بحد ذاتها وين موجوده
موجوده على السطح او صفائح الكترونيه او
كل هذا دراسات احنا كمهندسين معماريين
نتشارك مع المهندسين انشائيين ومع كل
الخبراء والعلماء دائما مشان نطور اساليب
البحث العلمي تبعتنا
ونحاول نساعد دولنا دول المجرمه طيب نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه التوضيحات
كان معنا من عمان المهندسه المعماري
والباحث في اداره المخاطر يزن محادين شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]